the president's press Secretary's
apologize for trying to compare Syrian
President Assad and last week's poison
gas attack to the Nazis Sean Spicer told
reporters that serious use of chemical
weapons crossed a line that even Adolphe
Hitler never did the statement in the
midst of Passover did not recognize the
Nazis use of poison gas to kill millions
of Jews and other prisoners chip Reid is
at the White House
chip good morning well good morning a
big part of the White House press
Secretary's job is to clean up after the
president but in this case Sean Spicer
is trying to clean up his own mess my
comments today did not reflect the
president's were distraction from him
and frankly were just misstated and
sensitive and wrong White House press
secretary Sean Spicer swiftly apologized
for comments he made at the podium in
which he said Adolf Hitler did not use
chemical agents on his own people we
didn't use chemical weapons in World War
two you know you had a you know someone
as despicable as Hitler who didn't even
sink to the to the to using chemical
weapons when asked to clarify Spicer
stumbled seeming to forget the millions
who died during the Holocaust in gas
chambers at concentration camps he was
not using the gas on his own people the
same way that a shot is doing it I mean
there was clearly I understand it thank
you thank you I appreciate that there
was not in the in the he brought him
into the to to the Holocaust Center and
I understand that at the Pentagon
defense secretary James Madison sinked
Lee spelled out what Spicer was trying
to say even in World War two chemical
weapons were not used on battlefield
even in the Korean War they were not
used on battlefield the backlash against
Spicer was swift and harsh in a
statement the Anne Frank Center said
Spicer's comments were the most evil
slur upon a group of people ever heard
from someone at the White House House
Democratic Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi
said Spicer must be fired and called on
the President to disavow his statements
I was Sean Hanna said it that's a
terribly terribly hard job ari fleischer
White House press secretary under
President George W Bush said the only
person who can decide if Spicer stays or
Gault's is the man he represents Shawn
works for Donald Trump and so long as he
is the president's confidence it's not
an issue the president has not yet
commented on Spicer's gaffe but he'll
have a chance to do so at a press
conference later today charlie chip the
New York Times I mean the New York Post
has a comment named Michael Goodwin who
Donald Trump is known for a long time he
did an interview with him in which he
said I like Steve talking about Steve
Bannon but you have to remember he was
not involved in my campaign until very
late and I'm my own strategist what's
the significance of this and what
message is he sending well it strongly
suggests that Bannon is on some kind of
super secret probation after his feud
last week with Jared Kushner who of
course is a senior advisor here but also
the president's son-in-law this is the
first time the president has publicly
acknowledged that feud he said to the
post Steve is a good guy but I told them
to straighten it out or I will the
feeling late last week was that Bannon
wasn't going anywhere
but yesterday afternoon sources began
hinting that Bannon was a non crucial
late comer to the campaign now it's very
well-known here the president is very
protective of his family so everyone's
waiting to see how Bannon responds
thanks Jim